punch him right in his face hello hey hi
there can you let me in how about you
let me in please I won't hurt you
maybe I am turning into the monster here
booth why do I always ruin everything
I just want this to be a nice normal
operation with are you bats or Chinese
all right up there with no gun oh I'm an
SCP now SCP ma RK IV Li ye are the most
lethal SCP around I'm not actually
lethal I just like to pop out of walls
and go ooh I almost walked right into
that Wow I'm just the biggest it ever
existed in the entire world I'm so
stupid
I never even bothered to try and jump
what kind of [ __ ] am I
to my 1 million fans thank you did I
ever mention now how older brother wanna
bang her boyfriend until you detect
something moving in horrible light
casting a shadow over you you blink
beginning to turn